i used to watch jeopardy when i was
younger but i admit it's been
decades since i've really watched
jeopardy but one of the big things about
jeopardy under the tutelage of the great
alex trebek
was that it was just about facts and
empiricism that's what it was about
and unfortunately that's the exact
opposite
of pseudoscience pushing dr mehmet oz
mehmet oz is like a tv he's a real
doctor he's there's no
he's a real doctor but he's also you
know like a tv doctor who appears on
different shows
uh often giving uh giving medical advice
and after the passing of longtime
jeopardy host alex trebek
jeopardy has tried a number of different
guest hosts and
this week uh or for a two week period
actually
the guest host is dr mehmet oz to me
this is pathetically embarrassing it's
you to put
a uh in front of for a show that is
supposed to be about just the facts
and empiricism to put in a guy who for
years has been peddling
all sorts of quackery and pseudoscience
seems completely antithetical to what
jeopardy is about
i don't really care in the sense that i
don't even watch this show
but there are tons of jeopardy fans who
are absolutely
furious about this and i have to tell
you i actually get it
i actually get it why do you put on a
pseudo-science doctor to host a show
about facts
a dr oz has previously uh pushed
various weight loss products including a
green coffee extract which is completely
and utterly not based in any kind of
science whatsoever
and in fact even the claims that the
company
based their uh marketing on
have since been retracted dr oz has
pushed the idea that gmos are
unhealthy now i know this is unpopular
with some on the left
there is no scientific evidence that
gmos are unhealthy
by virtue of being gmos yes there is
overlap between gmos and pesticides
and there are all sorts of deleterious
effects associated with
pesticides but there is not evidence
that
gmos are unhealthy i know some of you
will get mad and say david but
that's not been studied it has been
studied
go to scholar.google.com and find
endless peer-reviewed even long-term
studies on gmos
dr oz has pushed cures for the common
cold
including something called um calabo
root extract there is no science to back
that up
it can have side effects and dr oz has
pushed it
dr oz has talked about uh cures for
restless leg syndrome which include
putting lavender soap under your bed
sheets
because the floral smell may be relaxing
um no scientific research supports that
claim
he's talked about you know
do-it-yourself teeth whitening mess
methods that involve strawberries
this is not who should be hosting
jeopardy and i'm not arguing for anybody
to be canceled
i don't even care what jeopardy does
they can do whatever they want
but it seems like you know we actually
have a show here based on empirical
knowledge and facts
and you bring on dr oz i don't like it
you tell me
if uh you think i'm right or if i'm
wrong or if it just doesn't really
matter and i shouldn't even be talking
about it on the david pakman show